all right from OC to Beverly Hills are
you looking to pick up a diamond here
tonight Megan oh a diamond absolutely
um no no that would mean like join the
cast right I mean like I wouldn't say no
I'm pretty sure I just I asked Andy
Cohen at one point if I could be on
Beverly Hills but it's a lot easier a
flight from St Louis to LAX than is to
St Louis to SNA
well OC is coming back soon oh yeah I
know right they just wrapped
a minute ago
did you film it all for this upcoming
season while we see you pop up no but
I'm a big fan of Tamara being back on
and I like I I'm excited to see how that
plays out she kind of gave me some info
that I'm not allowed to share like
throughout the season and I gotta say
knowing everyone on the cast not
everyone I don't know everyone in the
cast but I know I know Heather I know
Tamara I know Shannon I'm not surprised
by anything Tamara said but the thing is
viewers will be surprised because they
don't know them like I do okay some
Secrets coming out did you hear from
Vicki after you shaded her a little at
the I Heart Awards the other night I
didn't shade her what did I say you said
she's back as a friend which is as much
as anyone needs to see a Vicky Gunnison
well I mean I feel like Vicki expects
that from me it's kind of like she just
never has anything good to say about me
it's kind of like our stick she didn't
give
she didn't give a damn whatever you're
allowed to say on this I don't know you
know every time I Google you the
continuing Saga have you and your ex can
just continues to populate the headlines
he recently he seems to be fighting you
for joint custody and making all these
statements against your character what
is your response to all that and what is
your hope for where this goes
Missouri's a 50 50 state where I live
Missouri and um
it's so interesting to me that he's
trying to make it a big deal that he
didn't get 50 50 custody and now he's
trying to it's like why would you want
to show that and I think it's wonderful
that my children's father wants to be in
their life 50 of the time
is HE capable we'll find out in the
courts and I and I have full faith in
the courts look at me do I look like I'm
worried do I look like I'm scared not at
all not tonight I just want the best for
my kids and I think that will is what's
going to happen how is heart doing
because that was another thing that he
said that you've mischaracterized
heart's uh disability and what's his
challenges I mean heart is heart is an
incredible kids I have never
mischaracterized anything with my the
love of my life he's my baby I've never
mischaracterized any of it the only
thing I've ever tried to do is
destigmatize his diagnosis of cerebral
palsy and pvl and which are two separate
diagnoses and
by doing that I have seen that I've
inspired other mothers other people with
CP even to to see that this is not a
limiting diagnosis and so I'm so proud
of my son to be able to like push
through that
he's gonna be fine he's always gonna be
fine that's the only way it can be
anyways he's an awesome kid you
described this year as your year of
exploring non-traditional things yeah
relationships included what's the
wildest thing you've let yourself
explore so far you already know the
answer to that which is why you asked
this leading question I actually don't I
really don't know of the wildest thing
well on intimate knowledge I talked
about my experience going on a date a
three-day date with a woman in New York
City and it was incredible and it was if
if you're more if you're more interested
in you know what happened and how it
ended up you should listen to my podcast
into my knowledge
foreign